j'ai remarqué que souvent les gens
regardent attentivement l'émission pour
ce qu'on peut y dire et ça a des
conséquences il y a quelques temps Cyril
sur mes yeux et je lui dis un jour Cyril
je vais me faire opérer des yeux à
l'époque je négociais avec les impôts
pour avoir un pied totalement quand le
monsieur des impôts a vu que j'allais me
faire refaire les femmes que je disais
que j'allais me faire refaire les yeux
j'ai reçu un mail que j'ai su montrer à
l'époque à Valérie me disant cher
Monsieur j'apprends que vous allez vous
faire une opération esthétique donc vous
n'avez pas de problème d'argent donc
j'annule l'accord fort on imagine donc
pour vous dire que ça peut avoir des
conséquences bon tant que c'était comme
ça je trouvais ça marrant marrant pas
tout le temps surtout de très mauvaise
foi parce qu'ils prennent toujours le
petit bout ou le la petite phrase etc
jusque là tout va bien il se trouve que
récemment j'ai eu une affaire voilà pas
une affaire judiciaire pas grave c'est
pareil c'est autour de l'oseille et
globalement normalement quand on quand
on a quand on est condamné quand on est
condamné on doit avoir un jugement qui
est motivé par quelque chose de de
juridique d'ailleurs un de loi etc là je
vous jure si rive sur la tête de tous
mes enfants que et j'ai montré
d'ailleurs à Gilles ce rendu j'ai été
condamné non pas sur des articles de loi
mais simplement parce que j'ai dit sur
ce plateau il y a très régulièrement que
je dépensais mon argent de façon
dispendieuse
je vous montre la phrase
somptuaire sur l'antenne de C8 millions
ces photos de vacances luxueuses sur son
compte Instagram c'est que sur ce qu'on
a pu dire sur le plateau c'est vrai en
plus
15 ans et en plus sur le compte
Instagram
je ne fais pas du tout de vacances
luxueuses depuis très très longtemps
donc ça veut dire que on peut être jugé
non pas sur ce qu'on sur des articles de
loi par rapport à ce qu'on peut dire sur
une antenne de télé et surtout qu'ici
quand même beaucoup ont dit beaucoup de
bêtises et on se barre
peu importe mais c'est un montage il y a
15 ans je trouve ça quand même très très
grave que que que TPMP dont on dit
souvent qu'il a une vraie audience dans
plein de domaines si maintenant on se
fait juger et condamner sur ce qu'on
peut dire comme connerie sur ce plateau
comme darka ou comme vérité mais les
vérités anciennes et qu'on est jugé sur
ces faits là je trouve ça je vous le dis
sincèrement et là je rigole plus
dramatique
ils ont le droit tu sais c'est ça qui
est terrible parce que par exemple si on
photo au restaurant quelqu'un vous prend
en photo et que vous êtes en train de
bouffer du caviar paf on peut vous
contrôler
c'est une décision judiciaire
je vous donne une idée cadeau pour moi
c'est Noël
j'ai jamais mangé de caviar de ma vie
c'est vrai non plus quand j'étais jeune
parce qu'on n'avait pas les moyens mais
maintenant ça va mieux et j'en prends un
peu mais comment tu sais que tu aimes
pas là si tu n'as jamais mangé et c'est
des œufs de poissons je sais que par
exemple
plein de choses
j'ai pas essayé tu vois pas d'un exemple
mais bien compris
ça me dit rien puis c'est un canapé
le kilo de caviar autour de 4 5000 euros
1 kg
il y a 20 ans
bleue bah c'est vrai quoi tu veux
t'acheter du caviar ah bah avant
j'aimais bien ça j'aime bien quoi tu
manges du caviar comme ça comme un quand
j'étais petit
je déconne je déconne
le plus que j'ai mis que j'ai acheté
deux trois kilos je pense c'est quoi ça
15000 boules
pour inviter des connards
c'est voilà c'est de temps en temps
on va manger du caviar chez Castaldi
c'était même au restaurant un célèbre
restaurant qui est sur les
Champs-Élysées qui s'appelle la maison
du caviar
là-bas il faut que ça et c'est vrai que
quand vous allez manger là-bas c'est
compliqué de s'en sortir pour moi de
ouais c'est pas vrai j'ai déjà mangé
là-bas
j'ai pris moi j'ai pris des salades
exactement
roulettes aussi
ça coûte pas cher c'est des prods arrête
avec ces conneries là de caviars
tu vois moi j'ai mangé des omelettes
totalement j'ai du caca
[Applaudissements]